demandes démontre la gravité la
situation à la suite de l' incendie de
plus de 5000 tonnes de produits
chimiques dans l'usiné brizola rouen il
convient de prendre la pleine mesure des
conséquences sanitaires et des villes
inquiétudes écologiques et économiques
qui expriment les populations les
professionnels intervenus sur le site
des réponses claires elles sans
ambiguïté et qui relève de l'état se
sont par trop fait attendre
une communication brouillonne
inappropriée et inadaptée à donner le
sentiment d'une crise très mal gérée par
les pouvoirs publics
sonic ce qui n'a fait qu'accroître le
malaise trop de questions restent sans
réponse aussi je vous demande madame la
ministre de faire la lumière sur
plusieurs zones d'ombré les leçons de
l'incident survenu en 2013 on et elles
ont elles été tirées et si oui selon
quel plan d'action les réglementation
seveso ont elles été intégralement
respectés et si oui
sont-elles à la hauteur des défis
sanitaires pourquoi avoir attendu cinq
longues journées pour publier la liste
des produits chimiques présents sur le
site de lubrizol
cette liste est elle d'ailleurs complète
enfin au delà des premiers résultats de
l'ineris d'autres analyses sont en cours
vous engagez vous allez rendre tout est
intégralement publics